and welcome to hannity we start with
this fox news alert former trump adviser
steve bannon found guilty no surprises
here on two misdemeanor charges after
refusing to cooperate with the sham
january 6 committee now this is the
first time a person has been found
guilty of contempt of congress charges
since g gordon liddy in 1974 they didn't
even put on a defense
take note by the way if you're a
republican or a trump supporter
yes the all-powerful january 6 committee
will drag you to court send you to jail
if you refuse to cater to their every
whim uh there's a lot more behind this
uh if you're a clinton lawyer named
michael sussman you get accused credibly
of lying to the fbi a jury of clinton
donors they're going to clear your vote
charges and you'll get away scot-free if
you're eric holder and obstruct justice
and obstruct congress rather no charges
no jail time no fine
we don't have equal justice or
application on our laws we'll have a lot
more on this coming up later in the
program also tonight this is a pretty
unbelievable story woman's suing a man
he didn't show up for a date
she's suing him and while the court
proceeding is going on she gets in a
huge fight
with the judge here's a preview
you have to look i'm not involved in you
you have to lay your please you have to
let your
complaint out it has you have to allege
this in the complaint you have not
you're going to love this entire tape
plus new york republican gubernatorial
candidate lee zelda will join us in just
a few minutes now last night the gop
hopeful and sitting congressman was
viciously attacked on stage during a
campaign event by a man with a deadly
weapon watch this
there's only one option
[Music]
that weapon could have gone right to the
carotid right to his heart thankfully
seldom was able to grab the attacker's
wrist it was very quick move on his part
and prevent serious injury before being
pulled to the ground following the
incident congressman zeldin tweeted
quote the attacker's words as he tried
to stab me a few hours ago you're done
but several attendees quickly jumped
into action tackled the guy zeldin
continued quote the attacker will likely
be instantly released under new york's
law
now anyway zelda was right because
shortly after the perpetrator was
arrested he was immediately released
from jail after posting
zero dollars in bail on his own
recognizance zero he tried to kill a
public official so let me get this
straight in new york state a person can
assault a public figure a sitting
congressman
a gubernatorial candidate try and kill a
sitting congressman and a gubernatorial
candidate with a deadly weapon and the
state is more than happy to let the
attacker waltz right out of jail no bail
on their own recognizance that's okay
this is shameful it is dangerous new
yorkers you should be mortified even
worse kathy hokel are you okay with this
does this sit well with you is this your
policy that you support
last night the state's far-left governor
pretended to be outraged by the attack
on twitter but prior to the assault it
was hulkel's campaign e-mailing her
supporters with every location all the
dates all the times of every lee zeldin
upcoming campaign events and suggested
that the republican candidate was an
extremist even today today after an
assassination attempt hulkel had her
stalker supporters following lee zeldin
now of course we're not blaming governor
hokel for the actions of a deranged
individual but you would think after
such an attack that maybe hocle and her
fellow democrats
might not send their supporters to
follow lee zeldin and maybe start
acknowledging that political violence
and extremism that's coming from the
left and maybe maybe they could publicly
denounce the doxing the stalking the
harassment that they're incentivizing
they're telling people where to go what
time to go
regardless of the targets political
affiliation they can stop
excusing for example arson looting
vandalism violence against the police
maybe we can bring back bail laws in new
york state and for the love of god you
would think they could please start
prosecuting violent offenders stop
letting them out of jail immediately
without bail and it's interesting
zeldan released this ad yesterday before
the attack even took place take a look
but alvin bragg has time and again
protected criminals at the expense of
law-abiding citizens using cashless bail
and his own lawless policies bragg has
put violent criminals back on our
streets and has turned neighborhoods
into danger zones and where is kathy
hulkel despite the pleas of new yorkers
hulkel has refused to use her authority
as governor to fire brag
it's not the role of the governor to
make those local decisions
now by the way that's the same d.a that
charged this guy jose alba the guy that
was working in the in the store the
bodega worker uh that the guy came
around assaulted him pushed him threw
him to the ground that started attacking
him he defended himself self-defense
they put that guy in rikers they charged
him with second-degree murder until the
public outcry
got the charges dropped for everyone in
new york around the country sadly what
happened to lee zeldin is not uncommon
in the past decade dozens of gop
lawmakers have been assaulted including
senator rand paul who will also join us
in a moment congressman steve scalise we
know was shot by democratic activists he
nearly died in that shooting in june a
man armed with a gun showed up to
justice kavanaugh's front door with
plans to assassinate him and by the way
since may 59 pro-life pregnancy centers
have been attacked vandalized or lit on
fire by the way as it relates to supreme
court justices they're still doxing
these justices they're still showing up
at their homes even though we have a law
u.s code
uh 18 1507 says you're not allowed to go
to a residence of a justice a court
officer or a jurist in any way or where
they work why isn't merrick garland
enforcing that law let's not forget
about the far left riots also in the
summer of 2020. remember democrats they
either lied to us and and said that they
were mostly peaceful they weren't or
they denied it was even happening and
said nothing or they came right out and
supported them like kamala harris we
lost dozens of americans thousands of
police officers injured billions of
property damage instead of condemning
this type of violence well we had some
top democrats
like for example maxine waters you know
she was telling her supporters to harass
republicans in public kamala harris
promoting that bail fund for violent
rioters after the police precinct was
burned to the ground said they're not
going to stop they shouldn't stop take
note beware just to remind you
they're not no it's not they're not
going to stop and that's they're not
this is a movement i'm telling you
they're not going to stop and and
everyone beware because they're not
gonna stop it is gonna they're not gonna
stop before election day in november and
they're not gonna stop after election
day and that should be everyone should
take note of that on both levels that
this isn't they're not gonna let up and
they should not and we should not
take note beware they're not going to
let up and they shouldn't let up chuck
schumer goes to the steps of the u.s
supreme court and threatens two supreme
court justices by name kavanaugh and
gorsuch
outside the supreme court nothing
happens to him take a look
i want to tell you gorsuch i want to
tell you kavanaugh you have released the
whirlwind and you will pay the price
you won't know what hit you if you go
forward with these awful decisions
you will pay the price you won't know
what hit you so democrats continue to
support violent behavior refuse to lock
up violent offenders what happened in
new york last night's what is that going
to be a daily weekly monthly occurrence
in every liberal state and city across
the country
my next guest is now vowing to fix the
broken system at least in new york hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else